this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
gastroesophageal reflux in children is a
condition in which liquid flows backward
or refluxes out of the stomach and into
the esophagus
the esophagus is a muscular tube that
connects the mouth to the stomach
it passes through a muscle called the
diaphragm
which separates the chest from the
abdomen
the passageway through the diaphragm is
a hole called the esophageal hiatus
the wall of the esophagus has slightly
thickened muscle layers where it
connects to the stomach these muscle
layers combined with part of the
diaphragm form the lower esophageal
sphincter
normally when a child swallows food the
lower esophageal sphincter relaxes
allowing the food to pass through it
then the lower esophageal sphincter
contracts to prevent food from refluxing
out of the stomach
into the esophagus
sometimes the lower esophageal sphincter
may relax even when the child hasn't
swallowed allowing food already in the
stomach to move back into the esophagus
this condition is called
gastroesophageal reflux and may have no
symptoms or only mild heartburn
however if the reflux is severe happens
often and causes more serious symptoms
the child has a condition called
gastroesophageal reflux disease or gerd
if the food refluxes into the esophagus
stomach acid mixed with the food can
cause irritation
if the food refluxes all the way up the
esophagus
into the throat and down into the
airways
irritation and infection of the airways
can also happen
although spitting up is normal gerd may
require a procedure called
funduplication
before the procedure the child will be
given general anesthesia to put him or
her to sleep during the procedure
a breathing tube will be inserted
through the nose or mouth and down the
throat to help the toddler breathe
during the procedure
commonly the surgeon will make five tiny
incisions near or in the belly button
and on the right and left sides of the
upper abdomen
and insert tubes for a camera and
surgical instruments
next the surgeon will carefully find the
lower esophageal sphincter near the
entrance to the stomach
the esophageal hiatus may be tightened
with sutures to prevent the stomach from
slipping into the chest
the top or fundus of the stomach
will be wrapped around the outside of
the sphincter
the wrapped fundus will be sutured back
onto the stomach to create a valve which
tightens and strengthens the sphincter
the fundoplication valve will help
prevent stomach contents from refluxing
back up into the esophagus
in some cases the surgeon may insert a
feeding tube also known as a gastrostomy
tube into the child's stomach while the
sphincter heals
this tube will deliver food directly to
the stomach and allow trapped air to
escape
finally the surgeon will close the
incisions with dissolvable sutures or
skin closure strips
after the procedure the child will be
taken to the recovery room for
monitoring
pain medication will be given
the child may continue to receive
antibiotics through the iv
within one to three days the child will
be released from the hospital
if the child has a feeding tube the
surgeon will remove it when he or she is
able to eat normally